ننول الاخبار العاجله على شاشتنا الجيش
الاسرائيلي يعلن سحب الكتيبه
271 التابعه لوحده الهندسه القتاليه بعد
اسابيع من القتال في خان يونس ومعنا من تل
ابيب مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام والمعلومات
المتوفره عن هذه الكتيبه ودورها
وايضا هذه الكتيبه رقم كم التي يتم سحبها
الان من
غزه زين واضح بان الجيش الاسرائيلي سحب
العديد من الالويه والكتائب التي شاركت في
عمليات القتال في قطاع غزه سواء كان ذلك
في المناطق الشماليه او الوسطى والان يبدو
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يبدا ايضا في تقليل
اعداد قواته في منطقه خانيونس بعد الاعلان
عن سحب هذه الكتيبه الكتيبه 271 وكان كما
تعلم قبل ايام قد سحب اللوائي اللواء
الرابع كرياتي مدرعات واللواء 55 التابع
لسلاح المظليين وبقي الان في منطقه
خانيونس خمسه الويه تعمل تحت امره ال
الفرقه 98 لكن الواضح بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي كما يبدو بدا يقلل من اعداد
قواته العامله في منطقه خانيونس وتحديدا
تلك الكتائب وتلك القوات التي انهت مهامها
القتاليه ونحن نتحدث هنا عن كتيبه هندسه
قتاليه عاده ما يزج بها في بدايه المعركه
في عمليه فتح المسارات و وفتح الممرات من
اجل تقدم القوات الاسرائيليه الراجله هذه
الكتيبه يبدو انها انهت عملها وتم اخراجها
كما سبق للجيش الاسرائيلي ان اخرج اللوائي
الرابع كرياتي
والخم مظلات وهنالك بعض التقديرات
العسكريه التي تشير الى ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي ربما يكون قد شارف على
الانتهاء من عملياته العسكريه الكبرى في
مدينه خانيونس وانه سوف يبدا في قاد من
الايام عمليات مماثله كتلك التي نشاهدها
في الايام الاخيره في المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه اي تقليل اعداد القوات الى الحد
الادنى والقيام بعمليات محدوده كما يجري
الان في مدينه غزه وفي المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه وسحب هذه القوات يبدو زين انه
ياتي ايضا في اطار الاعداد لتوسيع العمليه
البريه الى خارج نطاق خان يونس الى منطقه
او الى المناطق الحدوديه مع مصر هذا ما
المح اليه على الاقل الان رئيس الوزراء
بنيمين نتنياهو في مؤتمره الصحفي الذي
عقده هذه الليله حيث اشار الى انه اوعز
للجيش الاسرائيلي للاستعداد لاحتمال العمل
وتوسيع العمليه العسكريه في منطقه رفح
واشار الى رفح ب على وجه الخصوص وكان ايضا
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي قد اشار الى انه
ابلغ الوزير وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انتوني بلينكن بان الرد الذي صاغه صاغته
حركه حماس فيما يتعلق بصفقه التبادل هو
دفع اسرائيل لرفض هذه الصفقه وبالتالي
استمرار الحرب وتوسيعها الى مناطق اخرى
وهو يقصد بذلك ايضا منطقه رفح ومنطقه محور
فيلادلفيا الواقعه على الحدود الفلسطينيه
مع الاراضي المصريه لكن كان واضحا هذه
الليله ان بلينك تطرق الى مساله توسيع
العمليه العس عسكريه في رفح وقال بان على
اسرائيل ان تتوخى ايضا الحذر فيما يتعلق
بالوضع الانساني للفلسطينيين هناك واضح
بان الاداره الامريكيه تضع ضوابط ايضا على
هذه المساله مساله توسيع العمليه الى رفح
وهنالك ايضا مساله اخرى تتعلق في تنسيق
هذه العمليه العسكريه مع السلطات المصريه
على اعتبار ان الجانب المصري يرفض جمله
وتفصيله توسيع هذه العمليه العسكريه خاصه
اذا اراد الجيش الاسرائيلي ان يعمل
بمحاذات ذات الحدود مع مصر وتحديدا في
محور فيلاد الفي لكن بالمجمل العام واضح
بان تطرق بنيامين نتنياهو ووزير الدفاع
تحديدا الى مساله رفح هذه الليله في خضم
الحديث عن صفقه التبادل وياتي في اطار
تشكيل مزيد من الضغط العسكري او التهديد
بالضغط العسكري على المقاومه الفلسطينيه
من اجل ربما تليين مواقفها فيما يتعلق
بصفقه تبادل اسرى صحيح بان اسرائيل ايه
رفضت في الايام الماضيه بعض المقترحات او
الشروط التي وضعتها حركه حماس والتي تتمثل
بانهاء الحرب وانسحاب اسرائيل من قطاع غزه
لكن اليوم راينا ان بنيامين نتنياهو لم
يعلن صراحه ولم يقل نحن نرفض مقترح حماس
لكنه قال لا نستسلم للشروط التي وضعتها
حماس بمعنى انه يبقي الباب مواربا على
مزيد من الحوارات والنقاشات فيما يتعلق
بهذه الصفقه